decisions based on accounting
considerations can destroy a company
value in this video I will show you why
you need to understand the basics of
accounting in order to be successful in
your career hi everyone my name is
Heinrich and welcome to another episode
of firm learning thank you very much for
watching if you haven't yet please
subscribe to the channel below and press
the like button if you take any value
out of this video at all
accounting is something that many people
consider boring and I've seen even many
business students not taking a large
interest into accounting or even
completing a Business Studies degree or
Business Administration degree and not
really having understood the basics of
accounting even though they had some
kind of lectures in it in my opinion
this is a problem and for my experience
of having worked several years in a
large strategy consulting firm I can
assure you that it is absolutely
necessary for your career that you know
the basics of accounting and the reason
is that in business on a managerial
level many decisions need to be made in
which the counting plays a role managers
actually take decisions due to
accounting considerations and this can
often lead to decisions that actually
destroy company value just for the
reason that it might positively affect
some accounting figures so in order to
take part in these discussions you need
to understand these accounting
considerations so that you understand
your colleagues if they want to go a
certain path which might not be driven
by financial value but might be driven
by an accounting consideration and this
is not to say that these people make
these decisions because they are
irrational or because they don't know
what they are doing they have very good
reasons by the choose certain actions
which might destroy firm value just due
to accounting because of course
accounting matters if the company
publishes accounting figures which
aren't up to the expectations there can
be some real consequences
the compensation of managers is closely
tied to accounting figures and these
things are real companies can over value
these things over x2 the financial value
of the company and it is just crucial
that you understand these trade-offs in
order to be considered competent member
in the management group that you're part
of in this video I will give you two
tangible examples of situations how
accounting can distort managerial
decision makers these are two stylized
situations that actually you see pretty
frequently happening out there these
things are not just theoretical examples
but really happen all the time I can
tell you this for my experience and
having worked in several industries so
it's really crucial that you understand
these examples but make no mistake there
are many many other situations many many
other accounting driven reasons by
companies might take a certain route
which might improve certain short-term
figures but actually to value
distraction on a financial level so
let's jump into it
so the first topic is the distinction
between OPEX and capex so just the
preliminary remark this video cannot
serve as a full accounting primer but I
try to explain some basic concepts just
as a refresher but if you're completely
new to accounting if you did not have
any training in this topic at all please
look out for some more basic resources
this video will assume that you at least
have a basic understanding of how
accounting works so the first example of
what kind of accounting considerations
can actually destroy a company value is
the distinction between OPEX and capex
so OPEX and capex what is this here I
have the definition of Wikipedia OPEC
stands for operating expenditure it's
defined as an ongoing cost for running a
product business or system so this is
just the regular cost that companies
have so you can consider for instance
personnel costs here you
consider here costs for service
providers for rent that you need to pay
for the facilities that you run for
utilities for all these kinds of things
for business supplies the just other
costs of just running a business of
running a product so this is considered
epics operating expenditure Anoop X is
often contrasted by cap X cap X stands
for capital expenditure and it is
defined as the cost of developing or
providing non consumable parts for the
product or system and here are some
examples this is something that you
would usually consider an investment and
investment into something so for
instance buying a machine that then you
use to use products buying building
buying some land to use to build a
factory so thanks for you and invest a
certain amount of money today
for which you hope that you will get
returns so that you will hope that you
get some useful and your out of it in
the future
over a longer period of time so why does
this matter how is this distinction at
all relevant to managers making
decisions for their companies let's look
into how OPEX and capex expenditures
affect the income statement and the
balance statement and for starters in
one dimension of course they're
completely the same in the sense that
you need to pay now right from a cash
flow perspective it does not make any
difference if you have an office
expenditure or a capex expenditure right
so if you pay for capex or four topics
you need to pay now so this doesn't have
to do anything here this is the same for
both but there are differences when it
comes to the income statement and the
balance sheet and now let's look at the
to OPEX operating expenditure directly
goes into the income statement to the
profit and loss statement so if you
spend a certain amount of money for
instance for your personnel for your
employees then you report that as an
expense in your income statement in the
exact year that the expense has occurred
and implication of that is that if you
pain or instance 100 euro
hundred dollar to pay your personnel or
to buy office equipment or other
expenditures which are considered optics
then the profit here the earnings before
tax or then the net profit in the very
end that you will need to report will be
reduced by the exact amount of the
expenditure that you had so op X is
directly affecting your income statement
your P&L if you spend a dollar in optics
your profit is directly in that same
your reduced by the same dollar and this
is why managers of do not like up X
because directly reduces their net
profit directly has a negative impact on
the PNA right so let's not contrast that
with capex with an expense that you can
put as capital expenditure so again from
a cash flow perspective that's the same
you need to pay directly right now all
the money leaves your bank account buts
the difference this that it does not
directly go with your income statement
because it first gets into your balance
sheet
so that's imagine of for 100 euro or 100
million euro or whatever the amount
might be you buy a machine now in your
assets on the balance sheet there will
be a machine appearing with the book
value of 100 million euro or dollar but
it does not directly go to the income
statement so you do not have to directly
book an expense of 100 million in your
income statement so what happens instead
if you incur a complex expense there is
a depreciation schedule
so there's decided that each year over
certain defined amount of years a
certain portion of the capex expense
that you incurred will go to the income
statement as depreciation so if you have
no this machine worth a hundred million
there might be maybe a twenty year or a
fifty year
depreciation period so if now you have a
20-year depreciation period this means
that each year for 20 years you will pay
five million euro or dollar as
depreciation in your income statement so
instead of taking the directed of 100
right now in this year you suddenly only
need to show five as the depreciation in
this year and of course this has a much
better much more favorable net profit
effect especially in the short term so
what happens the next then of course the
asset the next year gets reduced by the
depreciation so if you depreciate it by
five million then instead of one hundred
on your bedroom sheet it will only show
five next year and so on and so forth so
again what does this mean for managers
and the truth is that even though of
course there are accounting rules which
prevent you to really truthing from
whether you put something as optics or
capex in reality you often have some
degrees of freedom whether you put
something as optics or topics so here
you could be in a situation where you
decide how you book something or maybe
you have to choose between two projects
and in the one project you can book and
expenses optics and then the other
project you can book as an expense as
capex so let's not not over long a
period of time how the decision whether
you have topics or capex expenditure
actually affects your income statement
so the first option is optics let's
imagine our company that earns for a
period of ten years revenues of 50 and
in order to earn these revenues of 50
they need to incur an OPEX expense of
100 and let's imagine just for the sake
of the argument that there are no other
expenses in this company so this working
to the situation that in the first year
you would show a profit of minus 50 and
then in the next years you would show a
profit of plus 50 because the optics
directly get spin and
effective in the very first year and
actually incurs and then you do not need
to book it again in the next year's
after so if you sum this up you get to a
situation where after ten years you will
have made revenues of five hundred so
tenths times fifteen you will have
complex expenses of hundred and
therefore a total profit of four hundred
so let's contrast that with the scenario
where you have a very similar situation
but instead of booking the same expenses
effects you are actually able to book it
as capex and now the situation looks a
bit different in the sense that in the
first year if you assume that the capex
gets depreciated over the full 10-year
lifespan of this project of this company
you only need to pay ten every year it's
hundred divided by ten so the result is
10 and the reside notice that at the
same revenues depreciation ten in the
very first year instead of needing to
show a profit of minus 50 you can now
show a profit of plus 40 but then of
course the downside is that in the next
year's
you have the same depreciation amounts
we already show the 40 as a profit and
as you can imagine many managers will
highly benefit the situation of the
capital investment over the situation of
the effects investment because they do
not want to show a loss of 50 in the
first year and there's many also
empirical studies that investors dislike
lots of uncertainty what the earnings of
a company are so it's often considered
favorably if you can smoothen out the
earnings over time compared to having a
situation where you have high jobs and
suddenly being significantly negative in
the earnings of a company of course the
second effect is that the compensation
of managers is often tied to the
earnings and you can imagine that the
personal compensation of a manager now
it's significantly better if the
padishah was a profit of 40 compared to
minus 50 and people tend to discount the
future in favor of the short-term maybe
also because this person only plans to
stay at the company for a certain amount
of years which is why capex investments
often gets favored and of course if you
add all of this up over the 10-year time
period you see that the revenues are
exactly the same the expenses are in the
long run exactly the same not only that
it's booked as depreciation instead of
optics and the profit is exactly the
same but you will see that managers
favor the capex investment for the
optics expenditure for these reasons so
why can this destroy financial value for
the company
when imagine that now you would have a
project with the payor profile of this
option one in front of you as a manager
and you would be able to earn revenues
often total five hundred over ten year
period by investing once OPEX one
hundred of course from the financial
menu perspective it would be beneficial
for the company to undergo with this
investment project but now if you would
be strongly incentivized as a manager
for the short term or maybe you are in a
bit of a tough financial situation with
the company you are under financial
distress you may be in a restructuring
process and have committed to certain
profit numbers your external
stakeholders into investors you might
decide to not do this option 1 even
though it would make financial sense for
the company due to the short term
negative effects in your books in your
accounting statements that this project
might have so now let's look into a
second type of examples and the second
type of situations that I have seen many
times of your especially in a retail
context but other industries as well and
this is the effect of which depreciation
schedule exactly you have on your
inventory on your assets and how that
depreciation schedule might affect your
decision to say or not to save certain
products in the future so let's think
about the following scenario you are a
buyer of the retail company that say you
are a fashion
an apparel company and you go out there
and you buy 50 units of certain
merchandise and you know that you can
sell the units in this year at a retail
price five euro per unit you know that
this is the fair market price of these
pieces and now you're able to buy these
at a value of two so sounds like good to
you right you can sell it at five and
buy it or two so now what does the
balance sheet at the beginning of this
year look like you have an inventory of
100 in the balance sheet because you
bought 50 units and a book value at the
purchase price of two so that just
assume for simplicity that purchase
price includes the book value and now
you go out there in the marketplace and
you start now to save these things and
in the first year you achieve to say 20
units of the 50 units that you initially
purchase and this for an apparel for
retail company is nothing too unusual so
you often buy a certain amount of stock
and then of course you try to sell as
much as possible as fast as possible but
after the season of course of mere some
stocks left over then you need to sell
again in the next season and because you
know that you get a retail value of five
per unit these 20 units now in your
income statement lead to a revenue of
100 now if you look at to the cost let
now go into the income statement for
these 100 revenues that you made this is
the cost of goods sold this is now a
cost of 40 why 40 because here now you
need to look at the book video right you
sell 20 units these units are in your
book at a purchase price of two so the
value of compared unit so 2 times 20 is
40 so you need to book costs of goods
sold of for the euro and this then would
lead to a profit of 60 s 100-40 so what
is now the situation in year 2 now you
have 30 units left in stock because
you're ready so it's 20 of the 50 units
that you initially have and now of
course the retail value of
these units decreased because usually
the longer you wait and the order your
merchandise is the price that you
actually get for the merchandise is
smaller and smaller and again you think
about a fashion company this is very
much true in the next season you will
usually only be able to sell the pieces
of last season at a significant discount
so let's now imagine for this Capilouto
example that instead of getting five you
can only get three now let's look into
the inventory and here not get it gets
interesting
because in this example now the company
decided to not depreciate the inventory
that they have right so they still
decide to keep a book value of two per
unit on the inventory and why would they
do that well if they do decide to
depreciate the inventory that they have
then they would need to show a
depreciation expense here in the last
year in the income statement in the same
height that they actually depreciate the
inventory that's left over and of course
for the reasons that we've seen in the
last example the company usually has an
incentive to depreciate as slowly as
possible because the faster you
depreciate the quicker the expenses show
up in your income statement and as said
you usually want to delay the expenses
to hit your income statement as long as
possible in order to show a positive
result for your company that is as high
as possible and again companies usually
have some degrees of discretion some
degrees of freedom to what extent they
depreciate the merchandise and here now
in this of course a bit extreme example
will be the situation where they do not
depreciate at all and you would still
keep the merchandise the 30 units of
stock and the book value of two with the
inventory of 60 so because now it's
already the next season you cannot sell
as much of it as the last season because
usually now you will already have new
action dies in which of course try to
sell with the focus but you still manage
not to sell 10 units of this Oh a lot of
inventory so 10 units at a retail value
of 3 leads to revenues of 30 and for
these 10 units now you need to book 20
euro of cost of goods so it because
they're still in your books at 2 euro
per unit so 10 times 2 is 20 and now you
would release the short profit of 10 so
let's not look into the next year now
you still have 20 units left in stock
and the retail value of these 20 units
there are not heaps of course decreasing
every year and now is only add to Europe
now what does the inventory look like
you still did not take any depreciation
expense because you try to delay that as
much as possible and now your 20 units
that you still have eat to an inventory
off for the Euro because they still put
that to Euro per unit and if you now
again managed to sell 10 units of the
stock you have no revenues of 20 because
10 times 2 but now you also need to book
cost of goods so it often and this then
needs to profitable 0 and now of course
the whole situation and it doesn't seem
that positive anymore and you see that
why do I even keep bothering selling
this if it doesn't give me any profit
and now of course when it really gets
unpleasant is now if you think this run
you further you stood up the 10 units
left they are now only at a retail value
of 1 so you can only get 1 euro for it
because it's not really old merchandise
profit already looks a bit old and not
as fresh anymore and you will only be
able to sell it as a significant
discount but unfortunately you still
have these 10 pieces in your books and a
venue of 2 because you just did not want
to depreciate it because then you would
have taken pieces in your P&L in your
income statement much earlier and if you
now even would have the opportunity to
say these 10 units at the retail value
then you would have to book revenues of
10 but the cost of goods sold would
still be 20 and then you would report a
loss for the sale of
ten and this is nowhere managerial
decisions really can come into play and
this will be a situation where some
companies will prefer to not sell this
inventory at all they will prefer to
just keep it somewhere in your stock to
let it rot away but not send it because
if you sell it you would report a loss
of ten and you do not want a negative
result in your income statement because
the company might already be stretched
because the market the company might
already fear that they do not reach the
unit targets so the Raza don't take the
sale at all instead of needing to take
the hit of taking a negative loss of ten
and this happens believe me I've seen
things like that very very frequently in
the corporate world people do not want
negative results on the income statement
and they would rather decide to just let
it rot instead of taking the loss of ten
and of course this is no situation where
you really destroy company venue because
even though of course you would report a
loss of ten in your income statement
you wouldn't be still get the money you
wouldn't still be able to get your ten
euro for the merchandise but if you do
not send it and let it just stay in your
stock pretty much forever then the
situation is that you will never say
this and of course if you know wait even
longer if you wait even more years then
some point you will not be able to sell
it at all or maybe not that many of 1
euro per unit maybe only at $0.10 per
unit so you would have the opportunity
to now get 10 euro for it but you do not
sell it because you do not want the
income statement loss even though your
company would be better off your
company's financial then you would
increase if you send it so this is an
engineering decision making driven by
accounting that really leads to a
destruction of company value or firm
value and this happens
things like that happen frequently in
the corporate world and if you do not
understand these accounting
considerations
you cannot take part in these managerial
discussions so these were the two
examples that I wanted to show
the reason again why I'm showing you
this is because I want to stress how
important it is that you have at least a
basic understanding of these kind of
accounting considerations even with
business graduates I often get the
feeling that many believe that as a
manager they make the important
decisions they will think about what's
best for the company and then there are
some bookkeepers somewhere to just take
care of the books and we'll just make
sure that somehow all of this gets
translated in the correct way but I can
tell you this is a clear misconception
on the c-level in large groups of
companies you can be sure that the
senior leaders of these companies have a
very good understanding of what the
accounting implications are of the
decisions that they take and these
things are very much top of mind for
these companies and if you just enter a
discussion just ignoring these
accounting implementations you will look
like a fool you will look like you do
not understand what matters to these 11
executives so make sure that you get
some accounting Basics in my university
studies there was one book which I found
really useful in learning exactly these
basics of accounting I left the link
through the book below in the
description to be fair it's a bit
expensive
but I can tell you it's really worth it
I bought it myself when I was a student
so if you would like a basic primer for
how accounting works it's really easy to
understand it goes into some level of
detail and I promise you that your level
of understanding will be much higher
than that of most of people and it's
also written and a fairly easy to
understand language so even a few so far
I did not have much exposure of
accounting this will help you so thank
you again for watching I hope you took
some value out of this video if you did
please press the like button and
subscribe to the channel to see more
videos like that I will at least post
one video every week please also press
the notification bell to keep
notifications whenever I bring out a new
channel thank you for watching I'm
highly
from five learning